i've talked before in my videos about
how much statistics and math you need
for data science
sometimes even i make fun of how much
academia hypes up machine learning
so this all begs a pretty natural
follow-up question which is
how much machine learning do you really
need for data science
keep watching and we'll discuss i'm
richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
now i did a video a little while ago on
machine learning books that i really
recommend
naturally i'll have a link to that video
in the description as well as
amazon links to those books but reading
books is not the only way that you can
go about
learning machine learning obviously a
lot of people do
love going that route but there are
things like andrew ing's famous coursera
course
you can go plug and play with different
r or python packages
there's lots of options out there but
let's just take a step back and think
about
what the most important parts of the
machine learning process are
in order to be a truly successful data
scientist
now i put this together by examining
those books i recommend
how they're structured and what contents
are in there
as well as my own personal experience
you'll find that with a lot of good
machine learning books they differ
in things like what data and examples
they use
how theoretical versus applied they are
and what programming language they
utilize
but at the end of the day they all do
cover a lot of the same topics
and i am a firm believer with a lot of
things if you understand
what it is that you need to learn in the
first place
you're going to be in a much better
position than most people now i'm going
to go through
10 different concepts in the machine
learning universe
that you should be familiar with and now
i'm not going to have time in this video
to go through
full lengthy descriptions of each of
these things or the video would be
massively long
but who knows maybe even i could be
convinced to do some separate videos on
some of these topics
so before we get into all these topics
just a few usual asks
number one hit the subscribe button and
the notification bell
if you haven't already the goal is 5 000
subscribers by the end of the year
also take half a second and smash the
like button
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
and then if you guys would be willing to
support me over on patreon
i will have a link to that in the
description and it would mean the world
to me if you guys are willing to help me
out that way
so one of the very first things that you
should be familiar with
is the difference between inference and
prediction
and i have a full video on this topic
already complete with examples
link will be in the description here's
the short difference
so machine learning can be used to infer
the effect that different variables have
on
some response variable you might want to
specifically estimate
what the effect these variables have on
the outcome
or you might not really care about that
you just care about what the most
important variables are
or alternatively you might want to
predict a particular outcome
given that outcome is well defined and
you have a set of other variables which
can be used as predictors
the distinction between these two is
absolutely critical
because at the end of the day there's
really nothing more important than
knowing the purpose of your analysis
and knowing what problem you're trying
to solve up front
but now that we're still on the subject
of absolute fundamentals
another thing which it doesn't get a lot
more fundamental than
is the difference between supervised and
unsupervised learning
put simply let's say you have a problem
where you have some kind of
outcome of interest it could be a
regression or a classification problem
where you're trying to predict that
outcome
or your goal may be inference it doesn't
matter as long as you do have that
well-defined outcome
up front you've got yourself a
supervised learning problem
but if you don't have an outcome
variable your goal may be just to create
clusters in that data set
or you may want to do some kind of
dimensionality reduction
but if you don't have that outcome
you've got an unsupervised learning
problem
and these tend to be harder another key
thing you need to understand
is the bias variance trade-off with an
emphasis on the difference between
overfitting and underfitting i'll have a
link to a stat quest video that does a
great job breaking down the difference
between these two
but i'll also try to do it briefly here
if you have a model that's
too complex generally because there's
too many variables in it
you're going to have a model with low
bias but high
variance meaning the model doesn't
generalize well to a test set
in other words your model is going to
over fit
but then on the flip side if your model
is not complex
enough you're going to have high bias
but low variance
in other words the model is going to
underfit
and there is no free launch there is a
trade-off between these two scenarios
so understanding that this trade-off
exists and how to think about it
is going to be really important the next
three items for this list all pertain to
methods
and really i'm dividing it based on
methods for three different kinds of
problems
and what i'll say to beginners who are
just picking up machine learning for the
first time
is that you don't have to be a complete
expert at these
with any method i think it makes sense
to understand at a high level
how it works what kind of problem it can
be used to solve
how to implement it in a programming
language of your choice
and then what the parameters are but
then later down the road
hey the more theory that you understand
behind that method
the better first thing you're going to
want to be familiar with is all the
different regression methods
and that starts with a very simple
linear regression
so this is going to be amazing when
you're working with a
client that's not necessarily super math
savvy
and you want to explain your results it
works whenever you have a continuous
outcome but it's not necessarily the
most powerful predictive model in the
world by any stretch of the imagination
you can make the method more complex
with various regularization techniques
you've got ridge regression you've got
the lasso
or you can put the concepts between
these two together
in what's called the elastic net then
another extension of the regression
approach that i'm a big fan of
is partial least squares and granted you
do have other techniques out there for
attacking problems where you have a
continuous response
but regression methods are by far the
most well-known
you probably guessed what the next item
on this list is
and those are the techniques for when
you're dealing with a categorical
outcome
that is classification methods first
method that most people are familiar
with
is logistic regression so it has all the
same benefits that linear regression has
with respect to interpretability
you've got the same options for
regularization
and it does have some wonderful
extensions in the case where you have
multiple
outcomes whether those are nominal or
ordinal
well logistic regression is just
scratching the surface of all the
different classification methods out
there
you've got decision trees random forests
k nearest neighbors support vector
machines
and of course everybody's favorite which
is the neural network
and now i do have to point out all these
things are
for the most part primarily used for
classification
but many of them do have extensions for
regression problems as well
but then of course i would be remiss not
to talk about techniques that you use
for
unsupervised learning problems now you
really do have to be specific
and ask yourself what type of problem
you're trying to solve when you embark
on an unsupervised learning exercise
but probably the most common type of
unsupervised learning problem
is clustering that is you're trying to
cluster the data set
into two or three or four or however
many different distinct clusters
now probably the most common approaches
for that
are the k-means algorithm and
hierarchical clustering
but your goal could also be
dimensionality reduction
and to that end a couple of the most
common techniques are principal
component analysis
and factor analysis but then another one
i really like
is t stochastic neighbor embedding
so all right now suppose you use your
method of choice and you get it working
a next follow-up question that's pretty
natural is how do you measure your
performance and evaluate how well you
did
for supervised learning problems where
you have a continuous response and your
goal is prediction
the most common metric for evaluation
is rmse that is root mean square
error now granted if your goal is
inference you're probably going to be a
bit more interested in goodness-of-fit
statistics
so things like adjusted r squared or aic
but for classification problems it gets
a little bit more complex
and a lot of it does come down to the
cutoffs separating your classes
so you have different metrics like
sensitivity
specificity and positive predictive
value
and then you have curves like the
precision recall curve
or the receiver operating characteristic
curve
and the corresponding areas under these
curves which broadly speaking
summarize the quality of the model and
how well it performs from a predictive
standpoint
that metric of success is obviously
highly critically important to just
seeing how well you did and with any
luck that's something that you establish
up front before you write a single line
of code
now these last three things all pertain
to different
data related issues that you are going
to run into
the first and a very common one is class
imbalance
this is the case where you're working
with a classification problem
but the different classes of the outcome
do not occur
at anywhere near the same rate like
maybe you have one class that occurs
like 90 percent of the time but the
other one only occurs 10 percent of the
time
spoiler alert this is the majority of
real life classification problems
because let's be real suppose you're
predicting somebody defaults on a loan
or forecloses
that's not going to happen fifty percent
of the time fifty percent of the time
people aren't going to get some disease
that you're trying to predict
and there's some different things that
you can do to try to alleviate this
problem
one of them is to do some sampling up
front to try to balance these class
rates
in both your training and test sets
another thing you could do if you have
only two classes
is just to use alternative cutoffs so
what i mean by that
is rather than classifying something to
the minority class
if the probability is 0.5 or greater
maybe classified to that class
if the probability is 0.2 or greater or
something like that
that's essentially what you're observing
with something like a precision recall
or roc curve or simply just try to
maximize your accuracy
for the minority class that tends to
work out a little bit better all around
so that item was all about the outcome
variable now it's time to talk about the
predictors
specifically we're going to talk about
feature selection
and i did a whole video about why if you
have bad data
you're going to have a bad model so
check that out links in the description
as always
now i'm a big believer in letting your
domain knowledge
handle the feature selection as much as
possible
but obviously in some cases that's only
going to take you so far
they're things like forward backward or
stepwise selection
for eliminating or adding features and
then also the carrot package in
r or the scikit learn package in python
can help you perform
recursive feature elimination which is a
more complex but incredibly powerful way
of handling this
now the last one is a topic that you
could write an entire book about
and in fact some have there will be a
link to one in the description
but that's feature engineering so let me
explain this one with some examples
if you use the z scores for sub
predictors instead of their raw values
that can make a huge difference if you
take the ratio between two predictors
and you drop those raw predictors
that can make a huge difference and
often if you have a continuous variable
and you discretize it that is you bin it
into two distinct classes
that can sometimes make a huge
difference this is a huge topic to end
on
and like many of these other things
oftentimes the thing that's going to
guide you the most
is your domain knowledge of the problem
at hand and many other times
it's technique specific but having said
all that
this can often be the part of the
process that you spend the absolute most
time on
so it's definitely something that should
be on your radar
there you have it that's 10 components
of machine learning that you should be
familiar with
like i always say this is not totally
comprehensive
and what you do is going to vary a lot
depending on your specific
job like your job might not have you do
any machine learning
or you might do so much machine learning
that it makes a west coast
ml engineer blush but i think these
topics will get you off on a great start
and if you're just getting into data
science and you know all these things
i think you're gonna do an amazing job
so thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it please consider
sharing it subscribe
like and leave me a comment down below
and let me know
what part of machine learning that you
think is the most important
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data